[Music]
number one apologies for absence we have
apologies from counseling and
to substitute members Council America
for non members attending 1993 agenda
item before minutes at the meeting held
on the 7th of January 2020 it should be
circulated to members so in mr. Jim I
have a query only minutes right before
we rush ahead it's not a question of
accuracy it's just a question of
completeness if members remember when we
were discussing the emergency rest
enters and volunteers and information
one of the major points that came across
was the fact that lack of communication
with Ward members and the officers were
asked to resolve that and that's big is
missing from the resolved so the
resolution to and I think that's a
significant part
because the year before the same request
was made and obviously a year later
we're still asking for that information
and haven't received it so it needs to
be put in there this raises if it's
training it wasn't training but members
as such it was including members being
included in the training Thank You Joan
if that just means that it's not so much
an alliteration it's it's an it's an
addition Thank You Germany wasn't there
was the two sort of points one around
actually having the training that is
given to the volunteers exceptional back
friendship also the fact that counsel
pointed out the ward members are not
contacted and they should be in that
sort of photo after a media action that
needs to be taken first the ward members
should be made aware because the
residence agenda item employed to
receive the declarations of interest so
moving on to item number six the Capitol
and treasury management special 2021 on
this item we welcome evening
and pass over to you just to run through
members
yeah so as such as indicated business
without our proposed capital and
treasury management strategy for the
next financial year and to recommend the
contents to more Council next week
subject to any questions or those
changes in that half so I think members
will be aware that as a local authority
we can determine our own program for
investments but we do so in light of
guidance produced by the ministry for
housing emotions of ermine and
residential code which does our
guidelines and for the way in which we
can invest all our money's so in setting
the strategy we've had due regard to
those sort of legislative frameworks and
and the city and the city for potential
code and the strategy itself is broken
down into a number of sections which are
detailed at section 3 so it sets out our
proposed capital expenditure for the
next financial year it sets out the way
in which we attend to finance our
capital program including if we weren't
opposing to do any borrowing it sets our
approach to our treasury management
investment strategy so which which
products or vehicles we would choose to
invest
the treasury management purposes it's
our approach to policies in terms of any
commercial investments the council might
wish to partake in and the knowledge and
skills that members and officers are
required to have in order to produce an
improved improvement strategy so in that
regard there's no significant changes in
terms of their content or layout of the
strategy as in previous years there's no
substantial change as I've said to the
actual investment strategy itself so
these or nature of the products that we
would put our money into so there's no
change to the investment strategy in
that respect and there's been a slight
tweak to the wording around section 11
which is our approach to current
commercial investments so members will
be aware that have been some discussions
in terms of possible and things that the
council might want to look at in the
future in terms of some more commercial
type activity so in particular members
will be aware that there was a briefing
earlier in the year in terms of the
Acela proposal to invest or to provide
loans to third parties in the local area
in order to support some rent economic
regeneration and growth in the local
area but as a decision on on
conservation in that farmers or indeed
any other sort how the commercial
investment type activities hasn't been
made at this stage obviously they're not
into the capital program or any of our
potential indicators at this point and
we agreed that those any such decision
about that kind of investment would be
subject to full council approval so at
this stage they're just big capital ones
treasury management strategy is not
proposing any sort of change to our risk
appetite all the type of things that
we're saying we will invest in but what
we are saying is if if we are looking to
happen betting that those sort of
opportunities over the next financial
year we would have to then bring that
strategy back to four counts alongside
any such decision paper so that the
strategy was reflective and
reflective of any such decision so at
this stage yet the capital internal
management strategy is not particularly
changed from previous years but it's
it's just in firms or maybe not and to
the fact that it might be something we
want to consider over the course of the
financial year but that would be subject
to a separate governance process so
that's probably all I was gonna say but
if if there's anything in terms of
clarity or alright the contents of the
report that any members wants to ask
then I'm happy to try to answer
questions thank you very much
Thank You mr. chairman a few questions
but prior to that the officer said there
was discussion around the Estella I'm
not sure that discussion is the word I
would put to that it was a presentation
and I'm pleased to hear that there's no
change and I would assume that any
change to the capital federal management
strategy would come to the review
committee before it goes to full
councils to so that it could be public
property looked at there is a new guide
on local authority investments by a sip
which is the Chartered Institute of
public financing accounts at sea and
that makes it very clear the council
should not borrow more than they need to
in order to clearly make a profit
obviously anything it also says they
should have transparency of the decision
making process so I think that's
something we ought to bear in mind for
the future as regarding this report I'd
like to ask a few questions of the
officer on item 1.5 previously we've
requested for section 1 5 1 under Sir
was required to report explicitly on the
affordability and the risks associated
with that strategy that has been deleted
from this report of just like to never
understand one and I think it was
duplicated twice so it's actually still
there at paragraph one paragraph 1.3
so I think I just deleted it because
there is two references to it but it's
still in there okay okay and second
question please bear with me
capital expenditure plans there's an
increase of one point zero three nine
million could you explain why there's no
information in there four point six I've
got my notes yeah so the capital
programs the proposed capital flows out
much subsea subjects to agreement that
for council next week has built into it
the post funding for the asset delivery
program or or the yeah the bit that's
profile plan to be profiled in the next
financial yeah so that accounts for the
sort of an increase in capital
expenditure because there's that
specific item which accounts for that
the majority of that increase but as
I've referenced them later on in the
report and also in the report to fall
council that decision is still subject
to the final business case for the asset
delivery program which will also be
taken back to call Council but that was
based on the outlined business case
numbers which we had it seems it's the
best estimate of length of the
investment we will require for that next
next year thank you and next mr.
chairman but not last and seven point
three for reference no big issue with
this except for the figures three point
four million two point eight point six
are exactly the same as last year you
know would have expected with financial
management with a year down the line
that's slightly more accurate or just it
figures to be there why have these
figures not been reworked could I just
ask that question okay
and I think I just needed to because
then we just agreed the outline business
case and for the asset delivery program
before the relevant meeting last year so
we reflected their figures in that
outline business case we haven't quite
got to the stage of the final business
case although that's plan through
percentage that's for Council in March
so because we haven't actually agreed a
change to the position at this stage
that's why the numbers have stayed the
same but it we are expecting those
imminently that in terms of the final
number so that obviously it will be
inflected and I've stated at the point
which we do have revised numbers too so
you have got the very finest numbers
which just not sentiment no well and
there's Memphis to be aware I waited
currently at the stage of assessing the
and tender of an agreement assessing the
bids and so we don't have a final set of
numbers I think I've played before a
display and then I change it once okay
thank you
and mr. chairman still not last 8.4
academic point for not just this one for
us why this has been added investment in
commercial activities of the widest
strategic objectives may be subject
different criteria than those applies
for funds invested purely for treasury
management purposes so I assume that's
just a cover
yeah I suppose I was just trying to make
clear that that counts with committed
under statutory guidance to make
investments for a number of different
reasons and that doesn't just have to
make investments for treasury management
purposes if if the council so wishes it
can apply a slightly different set of
criteria to the ones that are applied to
the treasury management which as your
where will be security the courtesy
yield in that order but it can also
choose to invest for other purposes and
a slightly different set of criteria and
as I set out in Section 11 in terms of
commercial investments we haven't got
any proposed Kenosha
it's time we actually defined set of
criteria but were we to go down that
path we would need to have a clear set
of parameters in terms of the risk we
would be prepared to to take and for
those kind of investments
just so you can just final question mr.
chairman you'll be pleased to hear does
the officer think it might be advisable
to look at the parameters potential
commercial investments prior to any
consideration of them so that we did not
and short notice of trying to drive a
strategy and very short notice
yes yeah so I mean I don't disagree that
it would be a reasonable thing for the
committee or and or in conjunction with
officers to look at the parameters in
which we might want to consider in terms
of any such investments I think the sort
of timing of the discussion or the
presentations we've had around and
things like the Acela that which we just
spoke about and hasn't really allowed us
to have that sort of full consideration
of what length parameters might be at
this time and from that respect haven't
be able to reflect that in the strategy
but I think that's something that would
legitimately we could work on over the
course of the next few months or years
so that members have gotten less of an
agreed risk appetite and sort of them
yes catch-22 situation in a way I think
just the timing wasn't ideal because if
we maybe mean considering that maybe six
months ago we maybe could have had put a
mortifyin certain parameters around it
in turn strategy but I think at this
stage it was just a bit than two last
minutes who sort of put into the
strategy at this stage but I agree I
think it's something that members might
want to give some consideration to yes
thank you thank you very much mr. Roy
afraid only observances races I think
the main was one was the last one was
Oscar suggest perhaps we add that as a
recommendation then we bring the some
scenarios and there is potential risk
parameter who have used to to this
council to consider for future
commercially investments from there
might be something to suggest perhaps
that meant to be back as part of the
mid-year strategy Zoe report yes I was
sorry chairman I was under the
impression I use that in line with what
I said I might be mean because that was
obviously I've been concerned and I was
wondering and that seemed to be quite
far forward in the presentation made to
us and I thought maybe I might be a bit
too late okay swing it forward before
that we could at this stage of acting as
any firm that lies in terms of when that
decision might be made or brought
forward and I suppose I'm not yeah
Liberty or informed not to say when that
decision might be brought forward
whether there is nothing there is no
proposal at this moment in time there is
investigation and the discussions is
finding out going on and if I may what I
wanted to say it was to sort of
reinforce an amount of what Naomi said
in her presentation the reports that
you've got in front of you is reasonably
similar to ones you've seen before and
your focus has been around section a
which is the Treasury investments and
looking at the gradings of where we put
the money the security that the year
under and so on and that that's been the
main focus but we're in a
evolving world the actual report is
quite comprehensive and covers a number
of different aspects of treasury
management
the council could get involved with the
appetite for risk that's been
demonstrated before has been around the
treasury management and they the short
terms investments and banks and their
relative ratings but not for any sort of
decision but that's the review committee
to consider what their appetite for risk
is because we have had a presentation on
a seller there's nothing there's no
formal proposal as yet investigations
are ongoing and the council's thoughts
are emerging and it could be in the
world in which we were in we come back
to you we in the in the reasonably near
future
with some more definitive proposals so I
just ask you to consider what your
thoughts are and yes you can you can
write things do need to move quite fast
and we do need to look at what our
criteria are for within our appetite of
risk but remembering that we're not just
looking at definitive commercial returns
we're looking at how we can support the
wider aims and objectives of the council
and sometimes they're quite difficult to
quantify and quite difficult for the
time scale off but there's certainly
something that we need to be considering
so the report today is along the same
lines of what what you've seen before
but please do be aware of its wider
content rather than the focuses that's
been there on previous occasions yes I'd
like to come back I'd like to comment on
like that so those remarks that been
made I think we've got to be aware of
our role we are an overview scrutiny
committee and our job is to scrutinize
and make
the council has all the information it
needs to act properly and it's it's
can't be a overestimated how important
that role is now I agree and I think we
should be preparing for this the council
Smith is quite right this report back to
item 11 is almost the same as previous
reports which is why there's been very
little comment and question because most
members here have looked at it in depth
before understand it and are comfortable
with it however when it comes to
commercial investments we haven't
considered that we haven't looked at the
risks we haven't looked at what now says
may or may not be suitable in different
scenarios and I think it's very
important that such detail that would be
needed is not done as a rushed pace that
this is done at a pace that this
committee can determine and is done so
that we can be in a position as a
committee should prepare from her to
prove three times I'd prepare for
council and have the information
available should it be necessary
I think bearing in mind the guide from
the local the Chartered Institute of
Public Finance that from what they're
saying that what I heard in a cellar
that it probably shouldn't be necessary
but nevertheless we have a duty to
prepare and I think a recommendation are
under 2.21 another recommendation would
be helpful so that we can look at that
risk and make sure that should such a
suggestion or proposal come to full
council that this committee is in a
situation where it can properly spend
analysis
countess - girls again
I mean treasury management materials in
December so I think that's rather a long
time to leave it right now the only
reviews in July and I still think the
annual review looking at of July is
you're still talking about sort of six
months away really I think ideally it
would be before then although I don't
know issues around April my full time
scales but it was about I think it's
right that there is proper proper
scrutiny but sometimes things need to
move quickly and it's not that were
looking there as said early there are
there are no proposals on the table at
the moment but should they come along it
might or it might not be that we need to
move quite quickly to their decisions
that would not be taken without the form
scrutiny of the full council and so I'm
not I'm not suggesting that review
doesn't have a part in that but in the
way in which councils work and the
structure of meetings and so on it could
be that if there was some formal
structure that meant the proposal had to
come to review prior to decision-making
it could be a an unnecessary unfortunate
time obstacle for council would make
decisions so take take take on board
what what you say but the proposals that
come forward mark might might determine
the
the framework of the scrutiny counselor
coming Thank You chairman yes when the
various visitors to places when people
looking at things that had invested in
various buildings or or other
institutions and one of the things that
clearly favored for us from that was the
fact that sometimes you need to move at
speed and what I wouldn't encounter
councillor Smith he's absolutely right
sometimes you have to move fast to grasp
that opportunity
I agree with any more than we want to
see something formally if you held up
that because yes it would have to come
before council investment board to make
sure we go forward you that we should
have things in place so they're all
there and limits and parameters so that
they cover that so that I think this is
part of the decision the only going
discussion round think about the assets
that we have the investments that we may
possibly have into the future and the
moment we still in the vision we have no
borrowing at all that and we're covering
all our debts by our by our own monies
and but of course we make much was a
situation where we do have to borrow but
of course we're in a good position to do
that so I think overall I think we're in
a good position to actually invest where
we need to but it has to be a proper
consideration of risk and opportunity
when we do that and I think that's what
all members want to see yeah I mean in
the report the kind of outline of
criterias already listed in bullet
points in the 11 goes into 12 I mean
wouldn't be much harm in formalizing
that as a kind of kind of checklist that
would really hold things up as long as
it satisfies each of those things and
then goes to the council it shouldn't
really have a lot of trauma to it I see
the point of formalizing rather
in the bottom part of the review report
but not putting us in a straitjacket at
the same time so there's but again
that's for debate at the time when the
particular case comes up so we normal
for formalizing a little bit because I
can't see any harm in reason these are
quite prudent just something I do share
some members concerns about the times in
the stream I think I think your if you
were prepared to bring it back at the
annual review then I think that at the
moment
seems like a fairly I think 30 month
both sides of the argument I think that
seems like the most sensible option so
hot under the impression that counts
dismissals if you can't even read
something acted on faster Rodney yeah
you said you would in case the stand
there there was no code of London to to
discuss at the moment I think I I don't
know the parameters of anything may or
may not come forward sorry I think
whether you use they're not amazing I
think it's it's to make sure that there
is the awareness of the committee that
there might be a time scale in which
allows for detail and time and schedule
of meetings there might be something
that comes along that doesn't quite give
us up that amount of flexibility that be
a reason for trying to work something up
and as I say for whatever reason there
was any need to bring something back
quicker than this whole strategy would
have to be represented to full council
alongside any decision anyway so it's
not as though it wouldn't be any subject
do you think I know obviously you can
probably before that I mean I think our
new providers have since this report was
written and published sort of scalp up
their forecast again in line what you're
suggesting I think they now sniffing
they might not rise to one extent during
the year or at a later date and so
obviously they keep them under constant
them sort of scrutiny in review and we
get regular updates though again I think
just the timing of this is the latest
forecast we had from their kingdoms a
number of scenarios I don't see with
them reacts and everything I think it
goes to the table that is on page six
point six which cancer those tables
already expect to see some change it
will change some figures I do expect to
see
obviously captured expenditure has
already been touched at what anyone's
event another one there this I noticed
was the reserves here mock reserves
doubling and say that that that's the is
negative financing that's not actually
our total level of reserves and
something and reserves total is forecast
to come down slightly over the medium
prayers reasons which are getting to set
out and then sort of report to full
council there in terms of how we finance
the capital program and example the
commitments to fund the and playgrounds
expenditure that was made last year that
was agreed to be financed for in
particular sort of sources of income so
the action why I'm going to finance the
program cannot bear a year-on-year
depending on on what exactly is week
which we are spending the money on but
yeah it's your question yeah and one
thing is just about which is
substantially increase pencil positive
and so again that's how that so but
basically I'm spiders we're fine to use
the far funds the the capital program
that's not the entirety of the new homes
bonus but again that sorts about in more
detail their budget reports and those
are just out of interest and maybe a bit
cheeky or make loans to subsidiaries
open surprises parties
disgusting just there not at this so we
have in the past as your BA I made a
small line too and our local party
trading company which was repainted any
instance which we have done it so far
and I think again possibly through and
seller and other things there might be
opportunities for us if we so chose to
perhaps get involved in that sort of
area of activity if I wanted but again
at this stage we haven't quite any
specific crisis on the table but if that
is little variability so in terms of
obviously and improving economic
generation in grozny area going back to
commercial investments I mean we we know
the hazards program that we're currently
looking at and we take the presentation
of a set up but where else and who else
is likely to come to us with commercial
investment commercial ideas for us to
get involved with is he something that
people will come to us or we have
somebody actually going out looking at
this on our behalf
I mean where do we go from here I mean
it's very little bit of a plan in place
but where where we go action is who's
going to come to us or give us ideas as
to new commercial investments other than
what we currently already do yeah I mean
I think it's a good question and again
something that you might want to
consider maybe is warming up listen
reviewing in in July obviously you can
be so proactive or reactive to a degree
and things like the Acela we thought we
acted because there was an opportunity
there that sort of presented itself to
us although we have had some involvement
obviously but it's not something we were
necessarily going out and looking to do
necessarily but on the other hand if we
so chose you could proactively go out
and look for opportunities in the market
and obviously a number of authorities
are sort of practically good going out
and looking
commercial opportunities who is going on
looking from this administration yes so
at the moment I mean in terms about us
an officer level we're not practically
going out and looking for commercial
investment opportunities because that is
not in line with our Treasury strategy
and we haven't caught there is also
support to do that but if members did
decide that was the strategy they wanted
to see you then on TV we could look at
resourcing that and practically probably
working with specialist advisors or yeah
you know which have to take specialist
advice in terms of that so other
authorities that have pursued the
program so I'm just one person
experience on a delicacy Essex County
Council they've got a commercial
property investment funds and they have
to employ a specialist advisors to go
out and look for opportunities in the
market and so I mean other authorities
have on that now really I'm not
suggesting that so what's the role of
the white British Council or not - it
depends on members off site but I think
yes it's not something we're proactively
going out and looking for at the moment
because it's not in line with our
strategy when the tour go now are
involved with a seller as a started its
further opened our minds as to ways in
which we can support the wider objective
so that the council in supporting our
local economy
wider economy things that can have
helped us but but also the the line of
thought about how the council is going
to fund itself going forward we've gone
through a phase of efficiencies and
economies with there's still financial
pressures are on funding and we're
thinking what a bit more widely about
Carol's council sustainability into the
future so it it's something that needs
to be there as a consideration but as
we've said that's not active right now
[Applause]
and our members for you include the
recommendation because that's forward
down so many nations in the information
that Street
it hasn't changed since last time it's
still around : register 2020 decision
the decision has been put into February
though just to allow time for the
December update
to agenda item number which is the work
okay I really just want to bring members
attention the Community Safety
Partnership as members asked last time
for its presence will be a police
presence at that meeting there will also
be a member of the Community Safety
Partnership as well and at this time I
haven't received some members said they
would like to get questions beforehand
so if I could just I wants them to email
me then I'll make sure they get included
in hope they can cover their the private
issue but also they get funded and how
much it is and what they're spending on
and then having is completing the
priority
sorry Jenny
sorry okay cause you could um
Oh question throats - every time I
thought I'd written how I will forget
probably because I remember every
meeting but they don't forget after that
is how they avoid duplicating funding
issues because obviously there's various
different organizations as you strategy
there's other ones which have small pots
of money and I wonder how they either
stop avoiding duplication of the same
effort or how they how they can measure
if there is duplication of it's worth
duplicating because of when you look at
the different possible money you'll see
the same applications from the same
application of sustainable ization storm
different pots of money and I just wish
know how that how they avoid the
communication of that or if they are
aware of the duplication if they measure
in two minute they're kept receptive or
if it's a way that they could work to
make these organizations receive a
reason about amount of money rather than
just a racial movement
laughter I want to speak on this item I
just want to speak on the work plan when
it's convenient
yeah thank you I'm sure we've all in the
way that we've read you know I don't
know the whole prepare chalice review I
must read it it makes sad reading the
overview and scrutiny committee has it
and I don't think this is on any
individual but it has obviously been
questioned as to the there are say
effectiveness of the committee I mean I
believe one of the comments that was
made was that it has rubber teeth now
I'm sure that is not the intention of
this committee and I'm sure this
committee will be your equally concerned
at the comments in here over fear
scrutiny what I think we ought to do is
rather than ignore it and there's always
a temptation when something's negative
to take it either personally or to
ignore it we shouldn't divide it those
it's not a personal challenge and it's
not something we should be ignoring I
think we all should look at this
corporate peer challenge look at it
under the review committee see if
there's areas that we can pick out in
areas where this committee can perhaps
improve it become more effective see if
it will help us
and so I'd like to suggest that's but in
the workplace so is there not an action
plan relating to this but it's not the
action plan is immature
[Music]
go through each other love to see the
action before we start doing that but
it's there's no reason why that can't be
public obviously to express my
disappointment any question come back on
that the action plan is is if isn't here
and it's not going to be the next
inspection would be two years bearing in
mind that some of these comments were
made in the previous report five years
ago I don't see why we've always waiting
for things I think this committee should
be more proactive rather than reactive
but if the members haven't got the
appetite to be proactive or so beer
I'll come time I'm in conversation with
the center of public scrutiny because
basically the peer review as you say
it's May commenced and it's possibly
better that we have them down to do an
independent review about scrutiny
function I mean they're saying that
we're over ambitious and under-resourced
mmm it's quite damning in places some of
these good yeah
and basically is it so we have an
independent look at it the same Republic
certainly come down and do a top to
bottom review and talk to members so
it's not offices as such doing it is a
I'm sorry shooting mr. chair too is true
that's going to be another repeat of
this process rather than trying to pick
up areas that we can improve on an altar
I mean it's up to this committee if this
committee wants it but there's not this
but things that affect this committee
and be proactive on it fine if it
prefers to wait for another report
so sometimes we don't agree and is
really but I agree that I don't think it
would be well and I think limiting the
amount of meetings we have left and they
mind I think that they could be put
forward as a subject but probably
teratomas the next review if it's
anything I have to say I can't comment
on this only got it today I was actually
missed from their original
sending out set of rules um I can't
actually comment on here this because as
I see Mason setup you ready no I haven't
no I so but that's why I can't come into
it
are you going to say that stone thanks
for coming
justice hm and I think an in-depth
review would be a really good idea and I
think we can really learn from that over
time I think it would be worth its
weight in gold because that's what we
want an independent committee coming
along and having a look at the way we
actually handle things rather than just
looking at something and then looking
internally at what we're doing I think
you need that helicopter view how things
are gone and of course you can learn
from that from other authorities and the
practices they have and we were you know
we should be learning or thority so I
think that's the way we really need to
take it forward but anything that's in
the action plan obviously would follow
up in any of it thank you Kevin
I'm not sure if they let me talk about
the whole peer review or just the part
of the peer review which refers to the
review committee with regard to the part
which talks about the review committee I
think you saw the knighted opportunity
for us as a review committee to look at
how we think we do work and now we
should work in relation to the report
and that way we might get a review
committee when she's designed by members
to scrutinize the council I mean but I'm
not sure but it ever been nothing like
that I think it's always been I think
the last reorganization of this was
based on the peer review and I think the
only thing it did was make the review
committee bigger than anything else I
think you might get many larger and that
was anything we just came out with
previous period here I think actually
this is talk about more fundamental
approach to reorganize much more nothing
less worthy has to do if we could get it
done before the May elections which
ideal whichever the place they but
certainly in the work plan then I agree
for the
and so the two points chair one was to
just essentially support that the people
have suggested you first suggested it
for it to reach the section two of the
action plan of things that we could pick
up and then roll over into the next
period the second point was a question
around the the action plan I don't know
if we have any basis as to when an
action plan is is expected it's not
mentioned in the the next items in the
back of the report but we are confident
that there is an action plan coming and
which is essential and a chairman but I
supposed to be honest the managing
director when the action coming I'm
presuming the collating information or
respondent and the members are happy for
that to go there's a subject for the
next yeah appreciate I think to announce
circles when I think if there is an
action plan coming we should review that
action plan and yeah without to date
it's very difficult to make the call on
that
[Music]